y luego de la información económica
pasamos a conocer lo que tenemos hoy
para revista de prensa y por ello le doy
la bienvenida en el estudio a Marta Moya
Marta muy buenos días Hola Andrés Buenos
días Marta vamos a abrir nuestra revista
de prensa con la investigación conjunta
que publicaron ayer varios medios
franceses sobre los entresijos del
secuestro del periodista Olivier tuvo a
un tema que lleva hoy a la portada de
liberación sí Andrés la portada de
liberación titula este miércoles
secuestro de Oliver dubá el turbulento
juego de la armada francesa en el
subtítulo destaca esta cabecera francesa
Qué ocurrió realmente el 8 de abril de
2021 Liberación revela el papel de los
militares que siguieron a nuestro
periodista a Olivia roboa hasta el
momento de su secuestro esto dice este
medio en portada pero vamos a conocer
que dice exactamente la investigación
Marta pues Andrés Esta es una
investigación conjunta entre Liberación
Lemon TV sandmon y la r
Esta es una investigación que se hizo ya
hace más de un año pero que solo se ha
publicado ahora una vez Oliver duboá fue
liberado el pasado 20 de marzo está
basada en 180 páginas de documentos
oficiales franceses y malienses
recordemos que Oliver dubá fue
secuestrado el 8 de abril de 2021 a
manos del grupo de apoyo al islam y los
musulmanes vinculado al qaeda en el
magreb islámico pero vamos a ir por
partes porque Oliver Dual es un
periodista freelance que colaboraba con
varios medios asiduamente entre ellos
Liberación vivían bamaco la capital de
Mali desde 2015 y en Mali también estaba
desplegada desde 2014 y hasta agosto de
2022 la operación militar francesa
barkan con el objetivo de luchar contra
el terrorismo y los grupos insurgentes
en el sahel en el norte de África
Durante este tiempo se hizo colega de un
local un joven
con el que estableció una relación de
confianza y al final lo utilizó como
fixer que es esta figura que utilizan
los periodistas en terreno con personas
locales para que pues les brinden cosas
logísticas traducciones o incluso
Fuentes en el terreno esta persona que
la investigación ha llamado cader Aunque
no es su nombre oficial porque está
reservado por motivos de seguridad
trabajaba con este grupo islámico en
misiones no bélicas y a la vez se hizo
fixer de este periodista pero el
problema no radica solo aquí sino que
también colaboraba con las fuerzas
militares francesas es decir que
podríamos decir que el punto clave de
todo es la investigación es que el
ejército sabía cómo se estaba gestando
todo Sí Andrés y todo se hizo a espaldas
del periodista o lidiar dubois el
ejército francés sabían todos los
movimientos del periodista que estaba
gestando una entrevista con el líder de
este grupo islámico y el problema radica
y de iba a la investigación una de las
conclusiones es que primero con esta
información el ejército francés no
disuadió a liberdúa de hacer esa
entrevista en gao en esa Región maliense
donde está radicado el grupo islamista y
segundo que no utilizaron esta
información para lanzar una operación
militar de neutralización a este líder
yihadista además sostiene esta
investigación que el medio francés
Liberación se negó a financiar esta
misión de dua y que fue el mismo líder
islamista quien financió la entrevista y
financió el vuelo a la región de gao
además con todos estos ingredientes el
ejército sabía Y no estuvo o no lideró
Esa operación ante lo que se preveía no
como efectivamente ocurrió pues una
emboscada que acabó con el secuestro de
Olivier dubá además esta investigación
sostiene que el 8 de abril el grupo
yihadista impidió
voy a enseñar a el fixer del periodista
por tanto el ejército ya se quedó sin
Pues el fixer i5 la información del
periodista y el paradero y lo que
también se extrae de estas
investigaciones ya por concluir es que
el mismo 8 de abril hubo una reunión en
la capital de níger El Perdón en la
capital de chat en la que altos
funcionarios en París Ya pues decían que
era una de las hipótesis que al final
acabara secuestrado duba y no Se tomaron
medidas para ello así que pues el papel
de los militares franceses en entredicho
en este secuestro del periodista Oliver
duva Marta y ya para cambiar de tema
ayer la Agencia Central de Inteligencia
de Estados Unidos publicó un polémico
vídeo para persuadir a los rusos y esto
entre muchos otros medios los reflejan
político y la CNN por ejemplo sí Andrés
una campaña de la Cia en redes sociales
sobre todo en Telegram que es el medio
que más utilizan los rusos una campaña
sin precedentes que publicaba ayer la
Cia y en la que intenta persuadir o
invitar a aquellos rusos que están o que
sienten desa con la guerra en Ucrania y
con el presidente Putin a que brinden
información a los servicios secretos
estadounidenses de Pues de cómo está la
economía o de Los Altos líderes y
funcionarios de la federación rusa el
vídeo empieza con frases como es
realmente la vida que quieres o es el
camino que usted quiere seguir y se vea
un hombre y a una mujer Pues a punto de
tomar grandes decisiones y que parece
que trabajan en edificios o
instituciones gubernamentales el vídeo
de la Cia acaba con una frase que dice
contactanos Tal vez las personas que te
rodean no quieren escuchar la verdad
pero nosotros queremos la respuesta del
kremlin Eso sí Este vídeo no se ha hecho
esperar Putin ha dicho que sus
ciudadanos estén alerta contra los
traidores Y es que recordemos que el
parlamento ruso el mes pasado firma una
ley por la que se aumentan los delitos
de traición Estatal de 20 años a cadena
perpetua Así que otra polémica más como
si ya fueran pocas el contexto de la
guerra en Ucrania Marta Muchas gracias
por
ver este repertorio en revista de prensa
nos vemos mañana en una nueva jornada
Gracias Andrés